depuis 2002 l'institution consultative
de l'agglomération locaux disent qu'ils
mènent l'enquêté auprès des habitants et
restitue son travail aux élus dernière
réunion avant le prochain mandat pour
ses 96 membres le thème la jeunesse
je pense pas que les plus vieux apporte
des réponses aux plus jeunes
je pense que tout procède d'un véritable
dialogue est ce qu a fait le codé ce qui
remarquable c'est cette possibilité d'un
dialogue entre des jeunes et des moins
jeunes ou entre des jeunes et des
institutions saint quentin en yvelines a
besoin d'attirer les jeunes
la tranche d'âge 18 30 ans manquent or
ces jeunes actifs sont nécessaires pour
les entreprises du territoire
le codis qui a mené une large enquête
auprès d'eux et l'a présentée avec des
tables rondes sur trois grands axes les
transports le logement et les loisirs
très intéressant c'est qu'on a à la fois
des positions d'élus donc en
responsabilité qui ont la capacité de
faire advenir des choses et puis des
échanges des acteurs de terrain qui ont
l'expérience de du vécu des jeunes à ou
de leur vécu eux de d'acteurs qui anime
le territoire l'occasion aussi de
dresser un bilan pour son président
après ses trois années de travaux et
réunion je trouve qu'on pourrait
remettre un peu à une autre place le coc
des skis qui n'est qu'une instance
participative et il n'est pas question
de prendre la place des élus mais bon
parfois un petit regret de ne pas être
entendus à la hauteur de 2 des travaux
qui sont effectués mais globalement
c'est vraiment une bonne expérience se
connaissent qui prendra fin en même
temps que les mandats municipaux
ses membres espèrent alors qu'il sera
renouvelée rapidement après les
élections du mois de mars